donc mes chers collègues nous sommes
saisis dans le cadre de la procédure
prévue par l'article 13 à constitution
de la candidature de Monsieur Benoît
Valley candidat présenté par le
Président de la République en fonction
de directeur général de l'Agence
nationale chargé de la sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail autrement
dit lancez comme vous le savez la
nomination du directeur général Lanset
est soumise à procédure d'articles très
en application de la loi organique
modifiée en la loi organique numéro
2010-837 du 23 juillet 2010 relative à
l'application du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la Constitution
je rappelle que l'anxess a été créé en
2010 à la suite du Grenelle de
l'environnement et qu'elle est chargé
d'évaluer les risques sanitaires dans
les domaines de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail la
vocation éclairée les débat public sur
les questions de sécurité sanitaire ou
le besoin d'objectivation scientifique
se fait fortement sentir régulièrement
l'actualité nous fournit des exemples de
ce besoin
monsieur valet a déjà eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer à différents types devant
notre commission notamment le 4 juin
2020 il est venu présenter sa
candidature à la présidence du conseil
d'administration de mon service nous
avions alors abordé les perspectives que
vous souhaitiez tracer pour l'agence
votre conception de ces relations avec
la tutelle dans laquelle pas moins de
cinq directions générales sont
impliquées et le partage des
responsabilités entre les ministères et
les agences sanitaires dans le contexte
de crise sanitaire notre commission
reste mobilisée sur le sujet du
financement des agences sanitaires
marqués par un net des engagements de
l'État et un passage de relais à
l'assurance maladie mais aussi de leur
bonne coordination ce qui est un sujet
de la tutelle alors que son premier de
concept que celui de ou annexe je
rappelle que la nomination ne peut
intervenir qu'à production devant les
commissions compétentes de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat cette audition à
publique elle sera dans votre qui se
déroulera à bulletin secret la
délégation de vote ne sont pas
autorisées le dépouillement doit être
effectué simultanément à l'Assemblée
nationale
en vertu du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 à la Constitution le
président de la République ne pourrait
procéder à ces nominations si l'addition
des votes exprimée dans les deux
commissions représentées au total au
moins trois cinquième des suffrages
exprimés monsieur Valley je vous laisse
la parole
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
suis évidemment tout à fait à la fois
heureux mais aussi impressionné d'être
devant vous en cette fin de matinée pour
la nomination à la direction générale de
l'anceste
je me permettrai de vous rappeler à ces
brièvement ce qui est lancé je ne doute
pas que les sénateurs que vous êtes et
sénatrice connaissaient bien mais juste
pour rappeler les quelques points
cruciaux notamment que cet agence est
assez jeune puisqu'elle a 12 ans elle
regroupe sur 16 sites du territoire
national près de 1400 agents donc c'est
une très très grosse
agence neuf laboratoires de recherche et
surtout il ne faut pas l'oublier 800
experts extérieurs qui constituent
finalement une partie de la connaissance
pour l'expertise et l'évaluation des
risques la première mission de cette
agence est d'apporter au décideurs
publics des repères scientifiques et des
recommandations donc c'est pas elle qui
prend les décisions de politique
publique qui vise à mieux protéger la
santé humaine contre les risques de
l'alimentation l'environnement où le
travail mais aussi ceux qui affectent la
santé des animaux et des plantes c'est
pour ça que il a été indiqué que cette
agence était de fait une agence
wannaëlle elle est aussi une agence
interministérielle puisqu'en réalité
cette agence relève des 5 ministères qui
ont été cités par madame la Présidente
les travaux de lancès alimentent
l'élaboration nombreuses dispositions
législatives et réglementaires et
peuvent aider les pouvoirs publics à
décider des mesures de gestion dans
leurs différents champs de compétences
l'enceinte l'ancêtre intervient
également comme opérateur et financeur
de la recherche publique j'ai évoqué les
9 laboratoires c'est un point très
important aussi de source de
connaissances d'agilité de l'expertise
puisqu'il y a une perméabilité entre ces
sites de recherche et les sujets
d'expertise pour l'évaluation des
risques que l'agence doit maîtriser elle
coordonne diffère dispositifs de
vigilance notamment la toxicovigence qui
s'appuie sur les centres anti-poison
c'est un élément qui est en règle
générale assez oublié où la
phytopharmaco vigilance depuis 2015 ou
encore la nutrie vigilance elle assure
des missions de surveillance et d'alerte
sur les risques émergents ou récurrents
et de fait elle s'adapte pour être
mobile et répondre à ces risques
émergents ou réitérer on peut penser par
exemple à la grippe aviaire évidemment
lancest assure également un rôle
essentiel en matière de sécurité
sanitaire en garantissant la qualité des
analyses officielles donc elle est aussi
d'une certaine manière certificatrice en
santé animale en santé des plantes et en
sécurité des aliments à l'instar des
laboratoires nationaux de référence qui
interviennent en santé humaine il a
enfin été confié à l'agence l'examen des
demandes de mi sur le marché pour
plusieurs familles de produits
réglementés en jeu sanitaires
spécifiques évidemment les phytos
pharmaceutiques les biocides et les
médicaments vétérinaires pour terminer
l'ancêtre participe aux travaux de
nombreux instances européennes et
internationales et ce sujet-là
évidemment très important aujourd'hui
pour nous
puisque en réalité elle travaille à la
sécurité sanitaire des aliments au
risque chimiques à la santé au bien-être
animal chant dans lequel elle exerce de
nombreux mandats de laboratoires de
référence européens mais aussi
internationaux
et qui donne évidemment à l'ancêtre une
place privilégiée au sein de l'Union
européenne où elle représente la France
à la demande du gouvernement
on peut évoquer de façon tout à fait
exemplaire le rôle de coordonnateur que
l'ancêtre s'est vu confié pour le 13
ambitieux partenariat européen pour
l'évaluation des risques chimiques qui a
été lancé lors de la présidentielle de
l'Union européenne en mai dernier c'est
un programme de 400 millions d'euros qui
associe près de 200 partenaires de 28
pays et trois agents européens c'est je
pense typiquement l'exemple du rôle que
l'on sait où apprendre pour stimuler la
recherche européenne et internationale
mais est aussi un influenceur de premier
rang donc aujourd'hui
présent devant vous c'est parce que je
suis candidat à cette direction générale
d'agence je pense que mon parcours que
je vais rappeler brièvement répond aux
compétences qui sont requises pour ce
poste donc le fait que je sois médecin
formé à la recherche avec un cursus de
recherche que j'ai continué d'accomplir
jusqu'à aujourd'hui puisque j'encadre
encore un universitaire pour une thèse
qui sera d'ailleurs soutenue en décembre
moi et dans quoi j'abandonnerai ensuite
ces fonctions de chercheurs
manager plusieurs organisations de santé
le CHU de Lille
la Direction générale de la santé de
2013 à 2018 enfin fin 2017 et la RS des
Hauts de France depuis 2020 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui j'ai contribué en 2016 en
tant que directeur général de la santé à
la mise en place des agences sanitaires
leur organisation ont pas la création de
ces agences
avec une fusion pour santé publique
France entre trois opérateurs pour la
veille et la surveillance
épidémiologique de la population donc au
travers de la loi de 2016 les produits
et pratiques de santé avec l'Agence
nationale de sécurité des médicaments
donc deuxième pilier de ces agences et
un troisième pilier qui est l'évaluation
scientifique des risques sanitaires
nouveaux notamment environnementaux ou
encore mal cerné avec lancest donc c'est
trois agences représentent
la quintessence même de notre
organisation de sécurité sanitaire et
d'évaluation des risques en tant que
tutelle j'ai pu saisir l'ancêtre et
apprécier la pertinence de ces réponses
scientifiques et j'ai participé à
l'élaboration de son contrat d'objectif
et de performance pour 2018-2022
je me suis engagé à l'époque aussi pour
la déontologie et la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts ce qui constitue la
première condition de la confiance dans
la décision publique on verra que pour
lancer c'est un vrai sujet d'importance
et que la déontologie suivie avec une
extrême vigilance et ce au travers de la
mise en place du site unique de
déclaration publique d'intérêt dans le
cadre de la loi 2016 dit Touraine pour
la transparence sur les liens d'intérêt
en santé
je revendique aussi une expérience
interministérielle pour avoir mis
ensemble plusieurs ministères de telle
sorte qu'on puisse réaliser des cadres
des politiques de santé publique
structurant pour l'action de lancès en
particulier notamment tout ce qui
concerne l'antibio résistance la
problématique du chlore bacon à l'époque
avec le plan chloredecon 3 mais aussi le
plan national santé environnement 3 et
le Plan Santé Travail 3 enfin et pour
terminer sur ce parcours personnel j'ai
été membre du conseil exécutif de l'OMS
de 2014 à 2017 j'ai été aussi acteur de
la mise en place du chantier initial de
l'Académie de l'OMS à Lyon en 2019 puis
ensuite j'ai au titre de la crise covid
travailler aux côtés du délégué
interministériel à stratégie nationale
du déconfinement et comme directeur de
l'ARS de 2000 depuis octobre 2020
de fait avec ces observations que que
j'ai pu accomplir dans ces fonctions je
me suis familiarisé avec cette vision
plus globale et transversale de la santé
qui n'était pas celle de ma fonction
initiale de médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur j'ai découvert beaucoup de
choses en marchant et ce à l'échelle
régionale nationale ou mondial ce qui me
semble être une vision qui parfaitement
cohérente avec l'émission de lancès au
titre de une seule santé c'est-à-dire
wenels pour les anglo-saxons
un point important évidemment qui a été
souligné par madame la Présidente c'est
que depuis 2020 en septembre 2020 donc
un mois avant que je prenne mes
fonctions de DG DRS
Hauts-de-France j'ai pris la présidence
du conseil d'administration de lancès
j'avais d'ailleurs demandé aux membres
du conseil d'administration s'il
souhaitait que je décline cette
responsabilité qui par analyse du de la
direction des affaires juridiques du
ministère de la Santé ne présentait pas
de lien d'intérêt suffisamment probant
pour en entraîner des conflits cette
président s'étant non exécutive mais
elle m'a permis cette présidence pendant
deux ans de constater au travers d'un
panorama très privilégié la qualité de
son activité et les valeurs qui sont les
siennes ainsi que sa relation qu'elle
est qu'elle porte de façon très
attentive aux administrateurs qu'ils
représentent l'état les organisations
professionnelles syndicales les
organisations de la société civile où
les personnels de l'ancêtre et plus
largement l'expression des attentes de
notre société
grâce à cette fonction j'ai
véritablement pu saisir le rôle de la de
l'agence au travers des défis sanitaires
qu'elle contribuent à résoudre de façon
quotidienne et appréhender ce qui me
semble être les compétences requises
pour cette direction générale j'ai
constaté que l'ancêtre est une agence de
référence dans le paysage français
européen avec un périmètre de
compétences parfaitement cohérent avec
ce regard global transversal sur la
santé qui constitue désormais la clé de
voûte de lecture des questions de santé
depuis la pandémie de covid-19 c'est un
sujet pour ce qu'il est s'il en est
aujourd'hui des questions de prévention
à travers des défis sanitaires qui sont
liés à l'activité humaine sur notre
planète j'ai également pu observer
combien lancès et attentives à la bonne
compréhension de ces travaux par
l'ensemble des décideurs et parties
prenantes faute de quoi leur utilité ne
serait que limitée et naturellement les
échanges qu'elle entretient avec vous et
qui sont nombreux
vous les élus du Parlement sont tout à
fait important et ils sont effectivement
soutenus puisque chaque année une
trentaine d'auditions aux deux
assemblées au temps de sollicitations
sont proposés je sais combien direction
les experts de Lancet sont à cœur de
répondre à vos demandes qui contribuent
pleinement à sa mission d'appui à la
décision et politique publique j'ai
aussi pu remarquer les nombreuses
interactions entre l'ancêtre et l'OPEX
qui peut se prémunir ou se garantir d'un
pouvoir de saisine à l'endroit de cette
agence au fil des conseils
d'administration auquel j'ai participé
j'ai noté le souci d'extrême écoute et
de dialogue de l'ancêtre en aval de son
action mais également en amont en effet
l'agence intervient sur de nombreuses
questions sanitaires nouvelles ou encore
mal cernées qui suscite des forces
inquiétudes et des attentes chez nos
concitoyens évidemment je citerai les
pesticides les nanotechnologies les
biotechnologies les ondes autant de
sujets je pense que vous soulèverez et
qui ont permis aussi à l'ange 16
d'installer un dialogue avec les
représentants de la société au travers
de dialogues permanents qui font partie
de ces organisations
un dernier point saillant doit de mon
point de vue et de souligné dans
l'évolution de l'encès j'ai déjà ébauché
c'est son implication forte et
croissante dans les dispositifs
européens qui mutualise les efforts
scientifiques pour renforcer la sécurité
sanitaire de l'Union et évidemment une
organisation comme celle du programme
scientifique que j'ai évoqué
précédemment le programme parc et clé
dans cette avancement de l'agence dans
ces travaux mais aussi la place du
directeur général de l'ancêtre au bord
de l'EFSA donc l'Agence européenne de
sécurité alimentaire
fort de tous ces constats en tant que
directeur général il m'importera de
consolider la force et la réputation de
l'agence si la confiance m'est donnée
par les deux assemblées pour les deux
filiers fondamentaux qui sont
l'excellence scientifique et la
confiance que son action suscite si
l'agence ne suscite pas la confiance les
décideurs politiques publiques ne
suivront pas les recommandations et donc
dans ce cadre là je m'attacherai à
renforcer la capacité de l'ancêtre à
alerter et agir avec un temps d'avance
pas toujours simple et occuper
pleinement sa place d'agence de
référence sur la scène française
européenne internationale pour terminer
je voudrais juste insister sur cinq
priorités sur lesquelles je pourrais
revenir lors de nos échanges mais qui
m'engagerait en tant que futur directeur
général la reconnaissance du rôle et
l'expérience de l'ancêtre dans la mise
en oeuvre de l'approche ou à nels sur
les santé humaine animales et végétales
où je pense que les personnes sont
nombreuses les interlocuteurs sont
nombreux pour créer des lieux ou
médecins vétérinaires un chercheur de
différentes obédiences puissent
dialoguer travailler ensemble pour
éviter de nouvelles pandémies de fait je
serai attentif à la prise en compte de
cette expérience très forte de l'ancêtre
pour des structures nouvelles comme le
comité de veille et d'anticipation des
risques sanitaires qui a été proposé et
qui remplace le conseil scientifique
mais en place pour la covid 19 il
m'importera également et en tant que
médecin j'espère en avoir les
possibilités de compréhension de pouvoir
renforcer les liens avec les
organisations professionnelles de la
santé humaine et leur cursus de
formation pour une meilleure
appropriation des travaux de l'agence
ainsi que des enjeux de santé
environnementale ou de santé au travail
qui sont souvent moins connus de ces
professionnels de santé
la deuxième priorité de mon action sera
le maintien du Vivier d'expert j'ai
mentionné 800 experts extérieurs c'est
très très grande richesse mais les
sollicitations augmentent et parfois
difficile de les motiver d'abord parce
que la valorisation n'est pas très
importante et que par ailleurs la mise
en application des déclarations
publiques d'intérêts amènent à limiter
un symptôme de recours à ses experts
donc il est très important que nous
puissions en bénéficier pour le travail
indé en disciplinaire au service des
questions sanitaires cette motivation de
mon point de vue implique une pleine
reconnaissance de ce type de mission
dans les parcours de chercheurs et dans
les potentialités de publications
scientifiques et pour tenter d'apporter
des progrès à ces questions je
m'engagerai à me rapprocher du ministère
en charge de ces sujets d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche pour voir
comment nous pouvons améliorer la
reconnaissance de cette expertise en
sachant qu'un rapport récent nous a
donné quelques recommandations à ce
titre
très sincèrement ce vivier d'expert 7
ans vous le savez les capacités
d'expertise de l'ancêtre aujourd'hui
vont vers les sciences humaines
économiques et sociales l'ancêtre a
souhaité renforcer cette année ses
capacités dans ce domaine de telle sorte
qu'elle puisse mieux cerner les
comportements exposants le plus à
certains risques sanitaires de tenir
compte des dimensions économiques et
sociales de différentes options d'action
le bénéfice risque et apprendre
certaines décisions et la contrainte que
cela peut imposer sur le plan de
l'organisation sociétale ou encore de
préciser les balances bénéfices risques
dans ces situations je verrai à la mise
en route de ces nouveaux développements
car il renforce la pertinence des
réponses de l'agence aux questions qu'on
lui pose
une quatrième priorité sera l'accès aux
données de santé une expertise
scientifique sera d'autant plus robuste
et rapide qu'elle aura bénéficié d'un
accès simple riche qualitatif aux
différents types de ressources
indispensables publication scientifique
bien sûr mais aussi résultats sur un
cpiologie indicateur d'usage de tel ou
tel substance ou produit résultat de
contrôle sanitaire sont des données à
croiser et on voit aussi que ces données
seront à partager entre agence sanitaire
et notamment les trois agences pivot que
j'ai mentionnés précédemment
pour terminer je veillerai à maintenir
au plus haut niveau la qualité des côtes
et dialogues de l'ancêtre tel que ça a
été instauré avec les parties prenantes
et avec la société qu'on retrouve dans
le conseil d'administration sa
composition grenélienne en est une
représentation tout à fait évidente et
en particulier je m'attacherai à la
bonne mise en route du comité de
dialogue sur les biotechnologies qui
débutera ses travaux cet automne et je
vous soutiendrai les initiatives pardon
d'associations du public dans le cadre
de la recherche ouverte ou encore le
développement des relations de l'agence
avec deux organisations nationales de
référence sur le débat que sont la
Commission nationale du débat public et
le Conseil économique social et
environnemental
voilà évidemment pour conclure vous
l'avez compris je suis très sensible à
l'attention que l'on sait se porte au
monde dans lequel nous vivons à son sens
du service public et si vous me donnez
votre confiance je serais vraiment fier
dans promouvoir l'action au profit de
toutes les santé et de pouvoir ainsi
m'engager pour que cette agence continue
de mettre à l'épreuve les barrières qui
se lisent parfois entre les disciplines
sanitaires et scientifiques entre les
registres d'action publique nationaux et
internationaux et aussi et surtout entre
la science et la confiance je vous
remercie pour votre écoute et je suis à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci Monsieur Valley et je passe la
parole à Florence lasarade qui a été
désigné rapporteur pour cette audition
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président le rapport de mars 2021 notre
commission sur la politique de santé
environnementale relevez la multiplicité
des autorités de tutelle de l'enses le
ministère de la Santé est en loin d'être
prépondérant puisque sa participation au
budget de l'agence et de l'ordre de 20%
le rapport préconisé de reconnaître un
rôle de chef de fil de la tutelle
stratégique de l'agence
au ministère de la Santé en tant qu'
ancien président du conseil
d'administration quel regard portez-vous
sur la multiplicité des tutelles de
l'établissement le même rapport de notre
commission relevait la permanence dans
le conseil d'administration de l'Agence
de représentants d'industriels et
d'exploitant agricoles et recommandé le
renforcement des garanties
d'indépendance de lagence plus récemment
un rapport d'experts publiée en juillet
2022 à comparer les politiques de
transparence et de gestion des conflits
d'intérêt des agents européennes
chargées de l'actuel l'évaluation du
glyphosate en Europe l'ancêtre s'en sort
plutôt mieux que les agences Allemands
nous suédoises par exemple mais dans un
contexte de défiance à l'égard des
agences de santé publique comment
améliorer la transparence des positions
prises par l'agence
et que faut-il en conclure sur la
coopération privilégiée contre tient la
ne cesse avec ses homologues européennes
comment voyez-vous le partage des rôles
entre les différentes agences
intervenants dans le domaine sanitaire
au sens large principalement entre
lansses et santé publique France mais
aussi entre l'anxess et le Haut Conseil
de la santé publique la complémentarité
c'est vue sur certains sujets comme
l'incendie du brisol ou sur le cluster
des concerts pédiatriques de
Sainte-Pazanne par exemple mais sur
d'autres comme celui de l'efficacité du
nutri-score la complémentarité a été
plus discutable y a-t-il lieu de
clarifier les compétences respectives
des uns et des autres
est-ce que vous disposez de statistiques
récentes sur les types de saisines de
l'agence en particulier de la part sur
les autoséines et sur les saisines à
l'initiative d'association agréée comme
la loi le prévoir
d'une manière générale les modalités de
saisine de l'agence et l'usage qui ont
qui est fait de ces modes de saisie ou
semble-t-il de nature à garantir la
réactivité l'efficacité et la
transparence de l'expertise scientifique
dans notre pays pour illustrer ce cette
question
je poserai une question un peu plus
précise sur le la reprise du réseau
aubépine de surveillance des eaux usées
par l'âne cesse est-ce que vous avez des
précisions à ce sujet
l'agence a-t-elle l'agence a-t-elle les
moyens de répondre rapidement à des
situations de crise ou d'urgence très
localisée par exemple entre mer je songe
au chlordécone ou Sargasses dans les
Antilles mais il pourrait en survenir
d'autres
sur les sujets d'actualité oui on fait
voilà
parce que sinon vous allez
ça vous va très bien
alors
merci beaucoup même la rapporteur donc
la multiplicité des tutelles me semble
plutôt une richesse qu'un inconvénient
donc ça en tant qu'observateur au
conseil d'administration mais aussi en
tant qu' ancien DGS puisque en fait elle
recèle cette interministérialité qui est
immédiate et ça permet des réponses
croisées sur des sujets d'intérêt qui
touchent à la fois par exemple la
consommation à la répression des fraudes
ou le contrôle de l'alimentation
ou des questions environnementales et
des questions sanitaires humaines donc
et très souvent évidemment la santé
humaine est au rendez-vous et vous avez
évoqué effectivement ce que ce rapport
indiqué qui était de donner un chef de
fil santé à cette multiplicité des
tutelles Vous le savez le chef de fil en
réalité il est reproduit annuellement
puisque
cette année en réalité le chef de fil et
la santé donc la Direction générale de
la santé en tant que directeur pour les
5 tutelles qui sont
présente à cette réunion des cinq
directeurs généraux qui ont lieu
plusieurs fois par an et d'année en
année c'est un autre ministère qui prend
la relève ce qui peut être amène à
partager aussi les responsabilités entre
les différents ministères tutelles et
notamment
rediscuter même si ça n'a pas été fait
récemment la participation de ministère
moins impliqué je pense notamment au
mystère du travail
il y a sans doute là un enjeu aussi de
contribution aux différents budgets de
programmes qui alimentent l'encès et qui
permet effectivement dans le cadre de la
plurie ministérialité de garantir d'une
certaine façon la complétude des moyens
qui peut être donné à l'encens je vais
vous surprendre mais je me pose
aujourd'hui la question de savoir si la
recherche ne doit pas elle-même devenir
une tutelle de l'agence puisqu'en
réalité il y a un très gros travail de
recherche qui se fait à l'agence et
c'est une agence sanitaire qui est
équipée de laboratoires de recherche de
très haut niveau avec une excellente
scientifique qui ne se démange jamais
l'intérêt de cette recherche et qu'elle
contribue à nourrir expertise et ça
c'est un point évidemment très très
important dans la qualité même de la
réponse à l'expertise mais
l'ancêtre en tant que organisation de
recherche n'est malheureusement pas
sollicité autant que peut-être on
pourrait le considérer quand on compare
avec des organisations comme l'Insee RS
et donc la part que pourrait prendre
l'ancêtre au sein des EPST et sans doute
un vrai sujet donc Roger Genet le
directeur général actuel a commencé
d'engager ce dialogue avec le ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur recherche et
donc c'est sûrement une question que
nous pourrons nous poser également dans
les mois qui viendront si d'aventure je
prends cette direction en responsabilité
je tiens à souligner que la loi de
programmation de la recherche par
exemple ne semble pas avoir introduit la
question du centre de la santé de
l'environnement dans ces financements ce
qui évidemment est un manque
considérable au regard de des sujets qui
sont sur la table en ce moment
est-ce que le directeur général doit
venir du monde de la santé humaine c'est
une question à laquelle je me
permettrais pas de répondre évidemment
et ayant ayant un conflit d'intérêt par
rapport à cette question
vous avez raison la défiance est un
sujet récurrent et donc de fait je pense
que
à la fois les règles de déontologie
c'est à dire la façon dont les
déclarations publiques d'intérêt sont
faites pour les différents experts qui
participent mais aussi pour les agents
eux-mêmes et pour les membres du conseil
d'administration garantie autant que
possible cette transparence elle n'est
pas absolue puisque c'est déclarations
d'intérêt sont de niveau de déclaratif
pour la santé on peut contrôler avec la
base transparente santé que j'avais
contribué à installer en 2016 ce n'est
pas le cas forcément avec tous les
sujets d'intérêt et peut-être là
faudra-t-il renforcer aussi la façon
dont la participation à un certain
nombre de d'organisations
parti prenante peut être plus
transparente et prendre l'exemple sur le
domaine de la santé dans ce contexte le
comité déontologie s'est réinstallé il
est à nouveau en ordre de marche il a
fait récemment un symptôme de retour
d'avis pour l'encens parmi ceux-là le
fait que on puisse considérer des moyens
substantiels de soutien à certaines
organisations qui feraient qu'un expert
en aurait bénéficié de façon indirecte
et que aujourd'hui ça n'apparaisse pas
dans les déclarations publiques
d'intérêts qui sont demandées notamment
évidemment des financements de recherche
conséquents pour des organisations
auxquelles cette expert appartient sans
qu'il ait eu lui-même directement
à en bénéficier
le comité déontologie ne peut pas être
saisi aujourd'hui par des partenaires
extérieurs donc il peut être saisi au
travers des membres qui constituent le
Conseil administration la direction
générale mais voilà ce sont aussi des
représentants des sociétés civiles ou
autres
qui de fait n'appartiennent pas à
l'ancêtre les membres du conseil
d'administration ne sont pas des agents
de lancer et donc c'est externalité et
en partie proposée s'il devait y avoir
une évolution dans ce cadre de ces îles
du comité du je pense que ça mérite sans
doute d'être examinés la complémentarité
des agents c'est un sujet qui m'a
préoccupé beaucoup quand j'étais
directeur général de la Santé puisque
j'avais proposé d'installer dans la loi
ce qu'on appelle le comité d'animation
du système d'agence qui notamment a
organisé ces trois leviers essentiels en
matière d'agence sanitaire pour les
aides à la décision de politique
publique ce Casa donc a été installé
dans la loi et il avait et il a toujours
un de travail qui favorise le
rapprochement des agences notamment
l'ancêtre et santé publique France où
l'ancêtre et l'Agence du médicament ou
santé publique France et l'Agence du
médicament mais aussi le Haut conseil de
santé publique en fait partie mais aussi
la chaise qui est présente même en tant
que autorité indépendante mais aussi et
c'est très intéressant les directions
tutelles qui participent aussi à ces
débats alors ils y viennent de façon
récurrente puisque ce Casa est organisé
environ tous les deux mois mais ils
viennent aussi de façon hebdomadaire
puisque on l'oublie toujours mais la
sécurité sanitaire dans ce pays est
organisé tous les mercredis matin avec
l'ensemble des partenaires que je viens
d'évoquer pour régler les questions
d'urgence en matière de sécurité
sanitaire de ce point de vue là lançait
c'est une agence qui se mobilise sur les
questions de crise qui déportent
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de ces
professionnels vers les sujets
d'actualité de crise notamment les
chercheurs qui peuvent se retrouver à
devoir assumer en urgence l'analyse
virologique ou bactérienne qui peut être
posée en question notamment pour la
santé en animal ce qui amène d'ailleurs
à des permanences d'activité très
lourdes pour ces acteurs et on peut ici
les remercier puisqu'en réalité on ne
parle pas d'eux quand on a des crises
comme la crise de la grippe aviaire sur
nos régions donc c'est une agence de
crise une agence qui se mobilise en
période de crise et il est important
évidemment de pouvoir le rappeler ici
la contribution de l'ancêtre aux
nutriscor versus santé publique France
et en réalité assez convergente même si
au départ le premier avis de lancer
c'est j'étais assez sensible au dossier
à ce moment-là le premier avis de lancer
sur les
dispositifs d'affichage nutritionnel
était pas très favorable mais pour sans
doute une raison importante c'est que
les dispositions qui avaient été
proposées étaient surtout des résultats
de laboratoire et n'avaient pas été
examiné autant en vie réelle qu'on
aurait pu le souhaiter et donc l'ancêtre
a émis son avis avant que
l'expérimentation vitre était faite en
France et cette experimentation virale
vous le savez a été entourée de beaucoup
de précautions de vigilance en matière
de réalisation
dans le domaine scientifique et a donné
lieu à la proposition d'une nutri-score
comme étant l'affichage nutritionnel qui
était le seul à même de changer les
comportements d'achat des Français
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
issus de classes aisées ou non-ausées
c'était un des points très important de
cette expérimentations viril qui s'est
tenue au cours de l'année 2016
aujourd'hui la contribution de lancer
sur les travaux du nutri-score elle est
réelle puisque vous le savez la base de
qualité des aliments est à l'ancêtre
localise et il y a un observatoire de la
formulation de ces aliments qui
s'appelle sikual et on regarde comment
les formulations changent un des impacts
importants de nutri-score c'est la
reformulation par les industriels avant
qu'il n'ait eu à afficher le nutri-score
puisqu'en réalité quand il s'engage dans
la démarche nutriscor certains sans
doute d'ailleurs pour des raisons de
marketing il faut le dire très
sincèrement en contrepartie ils sont
obligés d'afficher tous leurs produits
et c'est comme ça que vous avez des
produits affichés rouges qui sont
diffusés et parfois même avec des
publicités ce qui est assez intéressant
la reformulation c'est un point très
important puisqu'effectivement elle a
été conséquente un certain nombre
d'éléments d'évaluation d'une nutriscore
seront d'ailleurs disséminés dans le
domaine public prochainement de telle
sorte qu'on regarde si
ce dispositif apporté les les actions
qu'il était supposées apportées
maintenant on peut se le dire également
le nutri-score ne résume pas à lui tout
seul une politique nutritionnelle il a
aussi un certain nombre de fragilité et
si on prend l'exemple que vous avez tous
en tête j'imagine de des contaminants
dans l'alimentation le nutri-score n'en
parle pas et il peut vous engager à
manger plus de salade et que vous
puissiez vous trouver avec des salades
qui sont malheureusement avec un certain
nombre de contaminants donc on voit que
tout dispositif comporte ses faiblesses
mais qu'il a au moins de façon indirecte
impacter la qualité nutritionnelle
aujourd'hui dans notre pays même si
ceux-ci doit continuer d'être grandement
évalué
pour ce qui est des saisines elles
viennent principalement de nos autorités
gouvernementales donc des tutelles elles
sont nombreuses plusieurs centaines
chaque année
mais évidemment une partie de ces
saisines viennent d'associations qui
formulent des demandes par exemple il y
en a eu de formuler sur les sols
artificiels des terrains de sport sur
des sujets attenants à l'utilisation
d'un centre de produits par les
consommateurs donc il n'y a pas une
exclusivité même sur le pourcentage est
plutôt faible ou trop modeste puisqu'il
est de l'ordre de 10% et donc il y a
certainement à favoriser le dialogue
avec la société civile et la possibilité
pour celles et ceux qui veulent faire
des signes pour le faire l'OPEX vous le
savez à cette capacité et donc peut
travailler et le fait avec nous pour
pouvoir déposer des saisines je termine
sur l'aubépine donc c'est un réseau très
intéressant puisque c'est d'abord un
travail de recherche qui a permis de
regarder dans les eaux usées la présence
de la covid et avec un niveau de
relation assez net entre la présence et
la circulation du virus et
l'augmentation dans les eaux usées de ce
virus aujourd'hui il est pérennisé et
avec des points de surveillance qui sont
peu nombreux alors qu'ils ont été plus
nombreux pendant la crise covid mais la
méthodologie est acquise et le travail
joint avec santé publique France se fait
puisque les résultats sont affichés sur
le site de santé publique France
c'est sans doute un outil de d'alerte
pour la récurrence de la covid qui sera
d'intérêt je pense qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde reste suffisamment enclin à
utiliser les tests qui sont censés
sincèrement plus efficaces en matière de
renseignement sur la circulation virale
que ne peut être un dispositif même s'il
était diffus sur le sol national puisque
on ne pourra pas forcément l'avoir
présent en tout point du territoire mais
mais dans un moment où peut-être le
covid s'éloignera beaucoup de nos
préoccupations le fait de suivre comme
d'autres éléments dans les eaux usées
son retour donc pourraient nous
permettre effectivement de redéclencher
une situation de vigilance sanitaire et
donc l'usage notamment renforcer des
tests et d'autres types de de
système on avait utilisé dans les hauts
de France grâce à la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de Marseille le suivi
des eaux usées autour de la ville de
Dunkerque notamment au moment où nous
avions une recrudition très importante
de la covid en particulier autour des
eaux usées en aval donc c'était très là
très focal et très ciblée notamment en
aval de
d'établissements pour personnes âgées
dépendantes effectivement ça nous a
permis de faire des
travaux d'épidémiologie renforcés quand
effectivement on avale des eaux usées on
trouvait la présence plus grande de ce
virus donc c'était pour nous un
indicateur assez précieux de de
dispositions ciblées en matière de
vigilance et de suivi de la crise
épidémique voilà
je pense que j'ai pas dû oublier vos
questions merci
quelle sera la passer la parole à nos
collègues alors Bernard Chaumier qui
était co-rapporteur du projet merci
madame la Présidente merci à Benoît
Vallet alors juste une question en
complément pour être court de celle de
Florence la Sarrade puisque dans notre
rapport il y avait les préconisations
qu'elle a rappelé mais il y en avait une
qu'on va mettre en oeuvre dès maintenant
qui était nous proposions que le
directeur général de lancès soit qu'on
commémiquement à celui de santé publique
France auditionné par les commissions
compétentes en amont de l'étude du PLFSS
pour voilà pour parler des sujets
concernés soit tous mes collègues qui
sourient Monsieur le Directeur enfin au
futur directeur
le ministre de la Santé et maintenant
ministre de la santé et la prévention et
c'est une très bonne chose et il a
annoncé en présentant le PLFSS un virage
de la prévention et il a annoncé un
certain nombre d'érections qui relèvent
de la prévention médicalisée
qu'est-ce que le directeur de l'ancêtre
comment il lirait-il un PLFSS qui
porterait le virage de la prévention sur
les questions de santé environnementale
alors merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur chez Bernard giomier pour cette
question effectivement je pense que
aujourd'hui l'ancêtre dans son regard
sur la prévention porte ce regard de
santé globale et donc
demanderait que cette prévention ne soit
pas uniquement même si c'est évidemment
très important lié au bon comportement
favorable à la santé c'est sans doute
une vision de la prévention qui est
importante et qui reste à accomplir dans
notre pays et notamment que les
professionnels du soin s'emparent de ces
questions de santé plus avant on est
resté assez timide encore dans la
formation sur ces questions de
prévention même si le service sanitaire
avait l'ambition de permettre à chaque
professionnel de santé médecin
infirmière qui naît sage-femme etc de
pharmacien de partager ce sujet d'un
temps de formation à la prévention on
est sans doute en deçà de la main par
rapport à la possibilité que représente
cette puissance puissante armée
d'acteurs de la santé au service de la
santé publique mais la santé aujourd'hui
et aussi relié à ces questions de santé
environnementale ces questions
d'évolution climatique et ce qu'on
appelle l'entrepôtisation c'est à dire
le rôle de l'humain sur la planète
l'anthropocène qui est cet air dans
laquelle nous vivons aujourd'hui et la
prévention à mon sens doit se colorer de
ses éléments là d'ailleurs le ministre a
rappelé et Madame Firmin le Baudeau qui
est sa ministre déléguée et qui en
charge de la santé dans les territoires
et notamment des questions de santé
environnement que ces sujets wannels
c'était évidemment
crucial aujourd'hui
très clairement
très clairement ça sera ça sera il
serait souhaitable que ça soit assorti
de moyens en matière de recherche en
santé publique
notamment pour les questions de santé
populationnelle je cite toujours le
programme hospitalier de recherche
clinique qui date de 1993 c'est à dire
qu'il a 30 ans il a donné des résultats
considérables en matière de comparaison
des pratiques professionnelles mais
aussi des soins proposés pour les
Français et en santé populationnelle
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
l'équivalent donc il serait intéressant
de pouvoir déclencher à l'occasion d'un
PLFSS un vrai programme de recherche en
santé publique qui comporterait les
questions de santé environnementale
puisque je l'ai dit c'est un élément que
Roger Genet a signalé
à la nouvelle ministre de la recherche
et de l'enseignement supérieur madame
routaillot c'est que la loi de
programmation de la recherche ne porte
pas assez fortement cette question de la
Santé Environnement voilà pour essayer
de répondre à vos questions
c'est un sujet
sexe ou les regards de santé publique
France et de lancer sont certainement
intéressants et une audition des deux
directeurs générales me semble de bonne
aloi
si je peux me permettre évidemment
alors on va prendre les quatre questions
suivantes victoires jasmin a mis long
Xavier
victoire jasmin
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci aussi monsieur directeur futur
directeur peut-être
je voudrais revenir là vous avez parlé
des virus en fait des maladies des
risques émergents et bon moi je vais
venir sur les virus il y a des bactéries
émergentes il y a de nouvelles maladies
liées aussi aux mutations à la fois des
virus des bactéries et d'autres alors je
voudrais ici aussi savoir si vous
travaillez beaucoup avec les
collectivités bonsoir parce que je ne
sais pas de quel mois il vous disposez
pour les territoires d'outre-mer et de
façon singulière pour la Guadeloupe
parce que sur la Guadeloupe mais
j'aurais souhaité savoir pour les
actions de contrôle est-ce que vous avez
des moyens suffisants pour permettre en
tout cas
vous avez évoqué la prévention suite aux
différentes questions qui ont été posées
préalablement mais il y a un véritable
travail à faire notamment sur l'absence
de contrôle parce que de plus en plus on
voit qu'il y a des personnes qui
conditionnent eux-mêmes c'est un nombre
de produits ça peut qui est juste ça
peut être on fait un certain nombre de
produits alimentaires qui sont vendus
sur la voie publique alors avec les
collectivités qui donnent probablement
des autorisations pour la vente publique
pas forcément non plus parce que il y a
c'est un peu les protocole et il y a pas
forcément le respect des règles et des
normes en matière de sécurité
alimentaire en matière d'hygiène et là
ça peut avoir des conséquences
concernant les toxines et infections
alimentaires et de plus en plus on voit
que qu'il y a la ségrière des problèmes
par rapport à l'eau par exemple pour mon
territoire bon l'analyse de l'eau la
consommation de l'eau la qualité de
l'eau donc il faudrait qu'il y ait une
certaine cohérence et surtout des
contrôleurs il y a des contrats
sanitaires certains contrôles fait par
la RS mais je voudrais savoir si en
matière de contrôle des personnes qui
sont sur la voie publique par exemple et
des produits qui sont vendus y compris
sur Internet est-ce que vous avez la
main est-ce que vous vous
souciez vous bien en tout cas vous avez
une intention de travailler également
sur ces produits qui échappe
probablement à certains contrôles et aux
problèmes de la concurrence les loyale
par rapport à certains produits qui
pourraient s'apparenter à des produits
médicaux également et la dernière chose
je voudrais également
attirer l'attention aussi sur les
autorisations de vente de certains
produits également les autorisations
alors est-ce que c'est vous vous êtes
une des personnes des parties prenantes
pour les autorisations de vente de
certains produits liés à l'environnement
et des produits comment je vais les
qualifiés des produits qui sont qui sont
conditionnés de façon artisanale je
dirais mais qui sont mis en vente dans
certains
dans certains entreprises
officielles tout simplement et puis la
question de la lutte anti vectorielle
est-ce que vous vous êtes également
concernés par ces problématiques je vous
remercie
nous avons eu l'occasion de travailler
ensemble quelques fois et je pense sans
vouloir ici influencer la décision de
mes collègues que votre nomination pose
directement général est une bonne chose
pour l'ancêtre cela dit vous l'avez dit
c'est une agence de référence et
personne ne devrait remettre en cause la
pertinence de ces recommandations je
vais quand même reprendre deux exemples
deux affaires importantes à faire
Lactalis ou la faire Buitoni ou malgré
les recommandations que votre agence a
pu faire malgré les recommandations
qu'on peut faire les commissions
d'enquête du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est recommandations n'ont
pas été suivies d'effets sur le terrain
alors je voudrais vous poser une
question toute bête et toute simple
comment comptez-vous faire pour que le
recommandations met en place soit
appliquée sur le terrain
la question claire vous aviez Iaco
lancer a eu un rôle clé dans le cadre de
l'initiative européenne de
biosurveillance humaine prenons toute sa
place dans la définition d'indicateur
clé
pour définir au niveau européen des
expositions à des substances toxiques
ce partenariat européen va se poursuivre
et pourrait s'insérer plus largement
dans le cadre de la stratégie de donner
de santé européenne donc ma première
question quelle est le rôle pourrait
selon vous avoir lancés dans cette
coopération européenne et qu'elle
pourrait être les bénéficiaires au
niveau national d'un tel travail
européen et ma deuxième question qui qui
touche un peu plus aussi votre
expérience dans les territoires la
sédentarisation
représente notamment chez les jeunes de
11 à 17 ans un véritable risque pour la
santé des Français plusieurs mesures ont
visé à répondre à ce risque je pense par
exemple à la généralisation de
l'expérimentation en mission retrouve
ton cap visant à prévenir l'obésité
infantile qui avait été initié dans les
territoires que vous connaissez bien
dans le nord et le Pas-de-Calais
notamment puis généraliser dans la loi
de finance de la sécurité sociale 2022
selon vous quels sont les pistes de
réflexion envisagées pour répondre à ces
enjeux de santé publique il faudra-t-il
à l'avenir renforcer les travaux
d'analyse sur ces problématiques afin de
convenir d'outils ciblés pour assurer
que nos jeunes demeurent en bonne santé
je vous remercie
et pour terminer Cathy a pour ce poli
merci beaucoup monsieur vallée donc à la
tête de la RS des Hauts de France vous
aviez fait de l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et de la qualité
de vie au travail quand même des leviers
donc du pacte de la Fondation des
urgences quels sont donc vos intentions
en la matière s'agissant des personnels
travaillant à l'hôpital d'une part et
pour les salariés de manière générale
d'autre part ensuite j'aimerais vous
poser une deuxième question chaque année
dans les hauts de France plus de 32000
cas de cancers sont diagnostiqués et
plus de 15000 décès soit 3dc sur 10 et
ceux-ci sont attribués évidemment à
cette maladie la région de France et la
première région métropolitaine en termes
de mortalité pour cancer forte de votre
expérience quelle mesure envisagez-vous
pour améliorer la prévention et l'accès
aux dépistage et l'amélioration de la
qualité de vie et l'accès aux soins puis
j'ai juste une troisième petite question
en termes de matière de sécurité
environnementale la question de la
qualité de l'eau est devenue un sujet
nous le savons particulièrement sensible
et ça a été évoqué par plusieurs
collègues la période de grande
sécheresse rencontrée depuis le
printemps dans notre pays cumulé à
l'appel de la sobriété énergétique
nécessite des contrôles de la qualité de
l'eau donc renforcée ce contrôle assuré
par des laboratoires agréés par la RS
nécessitent-ils une mise à jour de ces
critères et de ses exigences je vous
remercie
répondre et ensuite Florent parler je
veux compléter quelques questions
merci beaucoup je vais peut-être
commencer par Madame à poursu poli
notamment sur la question des cancers
habitables
et la part que pourrait prendre les
questions de santé environnement sur ces
sujets évidemment le sujet des cancers
habitables ne peut pas être simplement
lié
au comportement de santé ça revient à ce
que j'indiquais tout à l'heure les
comportements favorables à la santé sont
importants mais aujourd'hui la
prévention passe aussi par les questions
de santé et d'environnement quoi qu'il
en soit
ce travail de territorialisation
finalement de la prévention vis-à-vis
des cancers habitables mais aussi de la
meilleure coordination de l'offre de
soins et un travail qui est typiquement
aux mains des agences régionales de
santé nous avons d'ailleurs installé
notre feuille de route cancer il y a
quelques jours pour 10 ans et avec
évidemment au devant de la scène c'est
ces questions propres à l'amélioration
des comportements de santé nous avons
ainsi envisagé dans ce cadre là de
renforcer la petit tabac puisque 30% de
prévalence reste le chiffre probablement
auquel nous allons assister lorsque
santé publique France nous redonnera
l'état de la prévalence du tabagisme
dans notre pays la crise covid
certainement va nous amener quelques
mauvaises surprises mais aussi la lutte
contre le surpoids parce qu'en réalité
le surpoids est associé et associé
également à une augmentation du risque
de cancer comme il était d'ailleurs
comme un facteur de risque linéairement
rattaché par rapport à la question des
maladies infectieuses et notamment de la
covid
les personnels des urgences et l'impact
sur leurs conditions de vie de travail
et pas vraiment le sujet de l'ancêtre
une question qui avait pu se poser à un
moment donné mais je ne l'ai pas vu
revenir était celle de la covid comme
une maladie professionnelle mais pour
l'instant l'ancêtre n'a pas été saisi
dans ce cadre-là et il est vrai que le
les conditions de de
finalement de contamination par la covid
était beaucoup plus renseignée comme
étant des facteurs extérieurs que des
facteurs intra-hospitaliers donc propre
à l'exercice du soin en tout cas les
travaux qui ont été menés dans ce cadre
ont souvent montré que c'était plutôt à
l'extérieur que les personnels se
contaminaient puisque au niveau du de
leur activité professionnelle il portait
les équipements de protection
la qualité de l'eau et vous avez tous
évidemment été sensibilisés par la
question des métabolites de pesticides
notamment en haut de France qui est
l'héritage de la chlorhydazone utilisé
pendant 40 ans pour la culture
betteravière intensive la qualité de
l'eau est un sujet effectivement
d'autant plus sensible que une partie de
la solution pour ces questions de
contamination c'est la dilution et donc
l'interconnexion entre les unités de
distribution et que la sécheresse
évidemment coupe un peu les moyens par
rapport à ces possibilités dilution même
si elle reste faisable et actuellement
alors que nous nous approchons pour
certaines communes d'un niveau de 3
microgrammes par litre et le niveau qui
a été retenu par les autorités
sanitaires pour prononcer la restriction
de consommation nous gardons encore la
possibilité d'un centre de solutions
avant de pouvoir appliquer après une
campagne de surveillance renforcée au
cours de l'été la consommation de l'eau
robinet pour quelques centaines
d'habitants des Hauts de France donc le
sujet évidemment est très important là
aussi la dynamique européenne de
l'ancêtre est certainement à souligner
c'est que on a besoin d'harmonisation
dans ces domaines les pesticides ont été
utilisés depuis des dizaines d'années en
quantité parfois très importantes mais
évidemment pas qu'en France dans tous
les pays européens parfois avec des
produits qui sont pas strictement les
mêmes mais avec des substances mères qui
sont similaires et donc il y a sûrement
une logique à définir au-delà de la
limite de qualité qui est aujourd'hui
une norme européenne et qui s'impose
comme une norme environnementale la
limite de qualité de 0 à microgramme par
litre pour les métabolites il y a
certainement intérêt à définir des
normes de d'action et de gestion de
l'eau lorsque ces valeurs de limite de
qualité sont dépassées et que les
métabolites peuvent être jugés
pertinents je rappelle ici
qu'aujourd'hui les métabolites de la
chlorhidazone sont jugées pertinents par
défaut et donc on a aucune idée
d'un niveau quel qu'il soit et je
reviendrai là dessus de la dangerosité
qu'il représente donc c'est un principe
de précaution excessif qui a été mis en
place quand je dis excessive je veux
dire par là que la valeur de 3
microgrammes par litre qui a été choisi
qui est la valeur choisie en Allemagne
aussi n'est pas assorti en Allemagne de
restriction de la consommation d'eau
donc c'est vraiment un souhait de
protection très important qui a été
choisi par les autorités sanitaires dans
ce pays donc l'ancêtre peut contribuer
au travers de sa dynamique européenne à
favoriser l'établissement de Vmax donc
de valeur sanitaire maximale ou de
valeur de de
d'exposition qui puisse être de niveau
européen
ça apporte aussi un centre d'éléments de
d'informations sur les questions de
biosurveillance puisque la
biosurveillance aujourd'hui vous le
savez et
finalement la possibilité de renseigner
la question de l'exposome qui a été
introduit dans la loi 2016 qui est la
somme des expositions tout au cours
d'une vie que ça soit des expositions
liées à des mauvais comportements de
santé ou à des bons comportements de
santé ou à des questions de santé
environnementale vous savez qu'il y a
des corps en France qui sont à la
croisée des travaux de santé publique
France et de l'ancêtre notamment l'étude
Esteban et qui renseigne sur un certain
nombre de présences de ce qu'on peut
appeler des contaminants des métaux
lourds ou des produits comme les
pesticides et la relation qui peut y
avoir avec des manifestations cliniques
et des maladies et c'est dans ce cadre
de travaux que nous aurons sans doute la
possibilité de serrer de plus près la
question des perturbateurs endocriniens
et de la définition qui peut leur être
donnée c'est aussi un sujet qui a été
abordé madame la sénatrice dans les
Antilles au travers du chlore des cônes
puisque aujourd'hui vous le savez
l'agence travail sur des valeurs de
toxicologie de référence interne et donc
qui correspondent à de la
biosurveillance et la présence de la
chlordécone dans le sang donc ça
s'appelle éclore des konemie et dont on
met pour les populations exposées une
relation avec des valeurs toxicologiques
de référence externe qui permet de dire
voilà quand il y a une exposition en
réalité ce qui se passe pour les
populations qui seraient exposées en
sachant que ça peut aussi guider les
réponses à donner sur la consommation de
produits ou non et la façon dont les
cultures par exemple se faire ou la
pêche peut se faire donc ces résultats
seront présentés et un travail très
important qui correspond à un deuxième
volet d'action du plan clordécone qui
avait été ouvert par le Président de la
République dans son mandat précédent en
décembre il y aura une très grosse
réunion à la Guadeloupe cette fois-ci
madame la sénatrice pour ses travaux de
lancest auxquels j'espère que je
pourrais être présent si vous me faites
confiance aujourd'hui évidemment
mais
si vous permettez et bien c'est un de
mes amendements voté par
mes collègues qui a permis qu'on soit
déjà à ce stade pour la couleur du
colimisation
en tant Quélus sont indispensables pour
sensibiliser les pouvoirs publics mais
aussi venir vers des agences comme les
nôtres pour qu'elles fassent les travaux
et les expertises attendues c'est
vraiment évidemment très important
vous savez que par exemple pour le
dioxyde de titane c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé il y a une sollicitation
importante des élus et un travail qui a
été inaugura au niveau européen par
rapport à cette additif donc
pour le bisphénolA ça a été la même
chose aussi l'ancêtre a été exemplaire
en matière de limite et voilà on a de
nombreux sujets donc
alors ça peut donner des conflits avec
l’europe parce que comme vous le savez
mieux que moi encore c'est que l'Europe
reconnaît surtout des règles de marché
et pas forcément des règles de santé
donc l'Europe de la santé c'est quelque
chose qu'il nous faut construire et très
certainement l'ancêtre est un
contributeur important pour ce
leadership qu'elle représente et donc la
capacité d'influence qu'elle peut avoir
au niveau européen et la possibilité
effectivement de faire évoluer un
certain nombre de décisions et de normes
et de reconnaissance de dangerosité de
produits
par sa présence et en particulier par
une présence objective
avec des résultats scientifiques comme
elle le fait dans le cadre du projet
sur la le projet parc donc et le projet
de d'évaluation des risques chimiques au
niveau européen donc ce programme qui
est doté de d'une somme de 400 millions
d'euros et pour laquelle l'ancêtre et
leader
je pense que je veux aussi parler des
autorisations que donne l'agence donc
qui est en complément
voilà alors les contrôles sur les
questions d'alimentation ou de
médicaments ne sont pas du domaine
d'expertise de lancer en tant que tel
mais plutôt de la direction de la
consommation de la répression des
fraudes ou pour les médicaments de la
part de la NSM
par contre effectivement des produits de
type
artisanaux relatif par exemple à des
conditions
d'engrais ou de d'utilisation
environnementale en soutien de culture
ou autre ce qui serait repéré par
l'ancêtre pourrait valoir des travaux
d'évaluation du risque et ensuite des
mesures de gestion qui seraient prises
par les ministères en charge donc le
ministère en particulier que porte qui
est porté par la direction générale de
la consommation et de la répression des
fraudes notamment on travaille aussi
beaucoup avec les consommateurs pour
repérer des produits qui présenteraient
des risques et qui se présenteraient
parfois comme des produits alternatifs
des produits bons pour l'environnement
et qui ne sont pas nécessairement et
donc ces travaux croiser avec l'ancêtre
peuvent donner lieu effectivement à des
résultats qui contredisent l'apparence
bénigne que certains produits pourraient
avoir vous savez que ça a été
le cas d'un symptôme d'essence présenté
comme bonne pour la santé et qui ne
présentait pas forcément toutes les
conditions de sécurité voulue
les autorisations donc le travail de
lancer c'est surtout sur la
phytopharmaceutique sur les médicaments
vétérinaires et sur les biocides en
sachant pour les biocides tous ne passe
pas encore aujourd'hui par des
autorisations de mise sur marché et que
donc là il y a un travail de repérage et
d'anticipation qui doit être fait par
par l'agence en relais des autorisations
de niveau européen quand elles existent
pour les phytopharmaceutiques la
substance active principale et évaluée
au niveau européen dans le cadre des
règlements européens et ensuite ça
déclinaison en produits
incorporant ces substances actives et
faites au niveau national par l'oncess
donc au titre de ces autorisations de
mission marché je crois qu'il est
important de rappeler ici que la
vigilance de lancer sur des
autorisations de mission marché de ton
plus grandes que l'expertise de
l'ancêtre s'exerce sur les questions
d'évaluation de risque par rapport à un
centre de ces produits et donc elle est
peut-être mieux à même de limiter
l'utilisation de ces produits ce qu'elle
a fait d'ailleurs au cours des années
passées puisque beaucoup d'autorisation
ont été retirés de telle sorte
qu'effectivement elle puisse
le mieux possible libérer des produits
dans des temporalités limitées les
produits sont donnés pour des périodes
limitées exposant le moins possible la
santé des personnes lorsqu'ils sont
utilisés
je crois que j'ai à peu près répondu aux
questions
merci pour vos mots très gentils
peut-être deux choses d'abord
on le dit pas suffisamment assez mais
Lactalis est typiquement le reflet d'une
coordination des agences sanitaires et
des tutelles très fortes et très
efficace vous savez que Lactalis parce
que c'était fin 2017 j'étais encore
directeur de la Santé a été un travail
qui joignait les centres de référence
notamment sur la salle menelle à Pasteur
qui ont reçu quelques échantillons de
salmonelle venus de médecin pédiatre qui
avait
identifié des syndromes
liés probablement à des consommations
chez des nouveaux-nés et des nourrissons
et que l'identification
similaire donc un une salmonelle de même
génotype dans ces différents
prélèvements diffusés au niveau national
à laisser penser qu'une source commune
était
en responsabilité et donc santé publique
France a fait son travail
d'épidémiologie on voit la
complémentarité des organisations santé
publiquement ça fait son travail
d'épidémiologie pour repérer l'acteur
commun qui donnait cette même salmonelle
chez les quelques nouveaux-nés
nourrissons qui avaient été identifié et
ils ont trouvé effectivement la
production Lactalis de lait Lactalis à
Craon en Mayenne avec la salmonelle qui
a été retrouvée sur le site avec les
services vétérinaires et donc le
ministère de l'Agriculture et l'ancêtre
travaillant sur cette référence de
salmonelle et le croisement avec les
travaux en santé humaine et le
laboratoire de référence de Pasteur
ce qui a déclenché effectivement le
travail de la direction de la
consommation et la répression des
fraudes pour arrêter l'activité de
l'usine de Mayenne et donc l'usine de
Craon donc Lactalis est le résultat
d'une efficacité des services croisés de
l'État au service de la santé et de la
protection des personnes bitonis a été
une situation un peu
identique le point que je voudrais faire
par rapport à ces deux situations et là
où peut-être non pas lancés mais
effectivement les autorités tutelles
peuvent peut-être renforcer leur demande
de contrôle c'est les autotests que font
les industriels et dont la connaissance
qui est faite au niveau des autorités
sanitaires n'est pas toujours pleinement
réalisée puisque c'est à leur discrétion
de fournir ou pas les résultats de ces
autotests donc je pense que c'est sur ce
point là où on peut sans doute faire
croître le suivi et la qualité des
organisations industrielles
bien Florence à Sarah me dit qu'elle a
une question très courte à laquelle vous
répondrait de façon très courte aussi
oui vous vous dites que vous voulez
améliorer et amplifier les travaux de
recherche mais
on a analysé que le budget de l'agence
que l'agence consacre financement de la
recherche ne s'élève qu'à 6 millions
d'euros
ça semble une force de frappe assez
légère pour améliorer la connaissance
sur certains sujets complexes le rapport
de la Commission sur la santé
environnementale toujours le même
regretter que les équipes de recherche
ne soient guère accompagnées pour
agréger leurs efforts et répondre à des
appels d'offres européen par exemple
est-ce que vous comptez et remédier et
comment
je pense alors évidemment j'ai fait un
plaidoyer sur l'importance de développer
des problèmes de recherche en santé
publique au sens le plus large et y
compris donc en incluant la question de
santé environnement les financements de
recherche qui sont affichés sont ceux
que l'on sait
obtient pour ses laboratoires notamment
en répondant à des appels à projets plus
une partie de financement et notamment
pour les réorganisations de laboratoire
pour permettre la rénovation d'incent de
Montreux vous savez qu'il y a un très
gros travail qui a été fait et on peut
remercier aussi les collectivités
territoriales qui ont participé à cet
effort de rénovation à hauteur de
d'environ 35 millions d'euros pour les
laboratoires de Lyon donc ils croisent
ceux de l'ancêtre et ceux de la NSM donc
les financements de recherche ne se
limitent pas simplement à au million que
vous avez indiqué par ailleurs l'ancêtre
et aussi promoteur de recherche
c'est-à-dire qu'elle donne la
possibilité
d'induire de la recherche avec avec les
ministères de tutelles pour des
laboratoires qui se tourne vers les
questions de santé environnement et
enfin et elle participe elle-même à la
réponse aux appels à projets de
recherche européen et son taux de
réussite est plutôt très bon puisqu'elle
réussit environ 28% des candidatures
qu'elles portent dans ces appels à
projets de recherche européen le projet
part en tant que tel est un projet
massif puisque lui c'est une somme de
400 millions d'euros qui est aujourd'hui
en route même si elle réunit plusieurs
pays investigateurs la coordination que
fait par l'ancêtre sur ces risques
chimiques un risque très pertinent par
rapport aux questions de santé
environnement montrent que la l'agilité
de la de l'ancêtre et de la Recherche
sujet est grand pour autant et je les je
l'ai aussi
référencé je pense qu'une intervention
et des échanges avec le Ministère de la
Recherche aujourd'hui s'impose ils ont
été initiés de façon très très
importante par Roger Genet dans le cadre
de l'installation du programme national
de recherche enseignement santé
environnement de travail mais c'est
vraiment un des sujets sur lesquels je
serai présent
l'idée que la nomination sera faite et
dès que effectivement
le caractère favorable de votre vote
aura été délivré ou non
il y a pas de procuration possible donc
merci madame je remercie mes collègues
de rester pour ce vote qui sera assez
rapide merci beaucoup